[Music]
from the studio that dominated the early
90s with the little mermaid Beauty and
the Beast and Aladdin comes an absolute
stinker they kicked off more than a
decade of garbage Pocahontas
meet Pocahontas a product of Disney's
underage third strap era she's a
princess based on a real 12 year old sex
trafficking victim transformed into a
dry land version of Ariel they expect
those rules to be obeyed you disobeyed
me daddy I love him I love him father in
this all Leg Adventure that's just a
little mermaid without the catchy songs
sense of fun or knowledge that they're
all about to die from war famine and
disease but uh look over there
pretty waterfalls
when you need an Australian to play an
Englishman who sounds like an American
to patronize an Indian you call Mel
Gibson we've improved the lives of
savages all over the world Savages he'll
play John Smith a guy as Bland as the
name John Smith would imply I'm John
Smith watch this Explorer discover he
has so much in common with Pocahontas
they're both hot their eyebrows don't
match their hair color
and that's it as these two characters as
thin and two-dimensional as the cells
they were painted on find love during
the time of colonization a big goof up
with plenty of good people on both sides
once two sides want to fight nothing can
stop them in fact the English would be
friendly if it wasn't for One Bad Apple
in this historical epic that teaches us
all the real colonizer was love all
along London is that your village yes
buildings as tall as trees I'd like to
see those things see there she didn't
have to be kidnapped back to London who
said anything about her being kidnapped
if I don't look it up it's like it never
happened
when you're not stuck wasting time with
Pocahontas enjoy your time with equally
boring Side characters like three animal
Sidekicks more bumming than Bob chayback
[Music]
a talking tree that's a little too
thorned up for Comfort I want to see him
again I want to see him again and he's
handsome too and a bunch of English
explorers who unfortunately weren't lost
at sea in the opening scene not a
thousand bloodthirsty Savages shall
stand in our way if any Indian tries to
stop me they'll blast him Savages could
be hiding anywhere do you think we need
some Savages these white men are
dangerous
so this Thanksgiving revisit an animated
musical whose songs range from
forgettable
too regrettable kill ourselves
or maybe two or three except for one
absolute Jam about how indigenous folks
are mythical beings with magical powers
instead of actual people who still exist
think my tribe are Ordinary People
and claim a land you think you can
explain
but we are all imbued with superpowers
we know magic we are Druids I'm
amazed I'm basically an X-Man or Avenger
Heron in the order I command and if you
cross me John you will discover
I can walk into this bird that's on my
hand and they'll never hear your voice
[Music]
I could blow you from this Lion King as
Mountain I control the ancient forces of
the wind if you cross me then I will
grind your bones to dust until
your just pieces
I can scatter
in
[Music]
with
[Music]
story
The Maze Runner
Porta John
90-day financier trash Bandicoot
Colonial American Psycho Mr Smee Chief
of Staff it's Giving Tree Wizards of the
Coast
and exactly what TLC warned us not to do
love at first White
[Music]
going back is his only chance he'll die
if he stays here so it ends with Jon
heading back to England to treat his
gunshot wound by boat is anyone gonna
tell him
by a Vengeance I am the Knight I am
Batman
thanks for the handkerchief Arthur
I have one power I never give up I know
I made a promise but I didn't see this
coming I didn't count on being happy